Oscar and and Tony Award winner Helen
Mirren has starred in dozens of projects
from the TV drama Prime suspects to the
film's Gosford Park and the Queen and
now she stars in one of my favorite
shows on anything the Yellowstone
prequel 1923 Marin plays Cara Dutton
wife of Jacob Dutton played by Harrison
Ford and the series explores how the
Dutton family fights to keep their Ranch
during their early 20th century it is a
gorgeous great show the show's debut in
December in fact became Paramount's
Paramount Plus's most watched Premiere
ever in the U.S I added to that Katie
and I I talked with Helen Mirren about
the show's success how she prepared for
this role and what we can expect in
season two we started with a clip from
the series
it's Vengeance you seek
never mind he'll be arrested in the
morning you'd rather put the bullet in
him yourself
then it's you in prison and the ranch is
lost all the same
you think it's you who suffered the most
how would you know you would sleep half
the time
well I bathed you and spoon fed you like
an infant I wiped like an infant
well I shoveled Graves
between 09 search prairies
and Helen Mirren joins us now that is a
great scene in a great show and it's
wonderful to be with you
um in the disclosures category Helen I
think I should tell you I've seen every
episode and as you may know they came
out at 3 A.M on Sundays every week one
per week and we would put the kids to
bed as early as humanly possible on
Sunday night so my wife and I could
watch so it's truly a thrill here
thank you we are a committed household
um as I understand it you took this role
on without actually seeing a script
beforehand I take it that is not the
normal order of things that is
definitely not the normal order of
things with Taylor Sheridan
um he said no I'm not going to let you
read the script there is no script
um because I like to write to the person
who I know is playing the role which I
thought was a great a great concept and
then of course Harrison and the fact
that Harris and I argue about this he
said I only took it because you were
going to be in it and I say I only took
it because you were going to be in it so
we don't quite know which one you know
stepped up first yeah I want to get to
Harrison in a moment but uh since you
mentioned Taylor Sheridan uh he must
have seen something fierce in you
because if he wrote the character for
you I have to say this character is
ferocious she is strong she is not to be
meddled with how did you connect with
the character I think for the strength
of the character there is no question
these Pioneer Women must have been
extraordinarily strong in a way that we
we can't comprehend now but in the wild
of the West you know it was every man
and woman for him or herself you know
you survival was the most important
thing so these people men and women were
extraordinarily strong characters
the um the series grabs viewers from the
very first scene which happens to be you
in an armed confrontation with a wounded
man you with a shotgun him trying to
load a pistol uh and a primal scream
what was the kind of training and
research process like for not only
embodying this character from 1923 but
handling their world I've had practice
with guns before because I played a
sniper in red one and then two so I had
had a gun training before but also by
riding the buggy when Taylor asked me to
do it I immediately said I don't ride
I've been on the back of horse many
times I've fallen off the back of a
horse many times so I'm I'm not a rider
he said don't worry I'll put you in a
buggy but I had to learn how to write
how to drive a buggy and and I came to
love my buggy and my horse who pulled my
buggy you you're terrific in the buggy
scenes uh very opposing even then
um so Harrison Ford I believe the first
time that you acted alongside one
another was in the 80s and as it happens
your husband and wife in that uh in that
movie as well and he says it feels like
you've been married for 40 years wow
perspective a very strange marriage
marriage was
weirdly very very familiar it was as if
as if we'd been in each other's pockets
all this time he carries the
um Charisma of being the film star that
he is with such ease I think that's what
gives him such incredible screen
presence well we're talking about
strength and ferocity uh your nephew in
the show Spencer uh we are awaiting his
return from overseas do we think we'll
see him early in season two
I hope so because I don't know if I can
write many more letters saying you've
got to come home Spencer we need you
I think I'll give up writing letter say
okay if you're not coming home I'm not
writing any more letters I suspect we'll
see him in Montana I hope so
I certainly hope so uh I think there's
something about the Dame that precedes
your name that is imposing you being
this woman of rank there in the UK uh
that people are surprised when you take
on roles uh Like Queenie in the Fast and
Furious franchise which I understand
you're coming back for and it's actually
based on a family member talk to me
about that yes it is my my aunt she was
the 13th of 14 children my mum and one
of my aunts was called Queenie Auntie
Queenie so I kind of Base Queen his
character on on my auntie Queenie and um
and also it's funny because I played the
queen so I thought that was quite funny
season one of 1923 streams on Paramount
plus it is awesome check it out